Hello, hello!
Oh my gosh, the timing for this stream and what I just got added for...
Okay, so I just got news about the Disguised Toast Round 2 Marble Rivals Tournament that's next week.
And then we just got the official teams for everybody.
And it's actually crazy because...
I am put in the pro category.
And literally, we got the list.
They're like, now you can talk about this event, the teams, and everything.
Like, six minutes ago.
Actually, six minutes ago.
And I thought it was so funny.
Because I was like, you see everybody?
I can link this because Toast just gave us permission to.
And like...
And like, okay.
I'm like, what the fuck?
Okay, look at who's...
Okay, by the way, Aimbot Calvin got brought back from the fucking grave to participate in this tournament.
I was like, Aimbot Calvin?
He's still alive?
I mean, we all know he's still alive.
But I was like, what the fuck?
We brought back someone?
We brought back Aimbot Calvin for this?
But like, look at the...
Surefour and I should have swapped places.
I was like...
Like, Surefour should have been in the pro category.
Why the fuck am I...
Because, okay, look.
It's Sleepy, Aimbot Calvin, More, Booger, Flats, Necros, Mendo.
And then there's me.
I was like, what am I...
What am I...
What am I doing here?
I should be like, here.
I should be on the Eternity category.
Surefour hit top 10 solo queue.
I don't understand.
Like, Surefour hit top 10 solo queue.
Why the fuck am I here at the pro category?
Better than Surefour confirmed.
Anyway, so yeah, this is my team.
It's me, Surefour, Ziox.
I think he's like...
I looked him up because like...
I was like, who's Ziox?
And he's like, better than Surefour.
He's a Genshin player, I believe.
I think, yeah, he's a Genshin player.
And then I requested Coney and Surefour to be on our team.
And then Toast suggested Nicewig could be on my team.
I was like, fuck yeah.
Fuck you, put Nicewig in here.
Ziox and Lulu, we're like...
I feel like our team is like everybody that has played Apex at some point in their lives.
Everyone's like, at some point, we've all played Apex somewhere.
I mean, I've interacted with Lulu before, but I've never interacted with Ziox.
And yeah, so...
And then like, okay, not gonna lie.
I think Necro's team...
I mean, I guess Necro's and Andrew are really good.
They're just gonna run Venom, Spider-Man.
I'm just gonna fucking ban Spider-Man and Venom.
Fuck these two.
They were running Venom, Spider-Man this entire time when ranked.
I saw them duo-queuing Venom, Spider-Man this entire time.
I guess like the... I don't know.
I don't know which team I match.
I think like...
Maybe Mor's team.
Mor's team is a little scary.
Because like...
Mor, Frex, and Timmy are both...
Individual-wise, they're all really good players individually.
And then, Surefour was like...
Was telling me, he was like...
Looking at the teams, and he was like, let's just run Mantis, Widow.
You on Mantis, me on Widow.
And then we can stomp some of these teams.
And I was like, cool.
Thumbs up.
Thumbs up emoji.
Like, that's our plan.
We're like, alright, yeah, sure, I'm down.
I'm down to fucking run around as Mantis with you.
Sounds about right.
But yes, this is the official teams for the...
For the Disguised Toast Marvel Rivals Tournament that's happening...
Next week.
So, half of offline TV is in here.
I mean, it's run by offline...
I mean, it's Disguised Toast Tournament.
Of course, half of offline TV would be in here.
Yeah, so...
I guess I'm categorized as a pro now?
Like...
Sure, don't be over sure for it.
It's not like sure for it.
Was signed to the Overwatch League.
And was in professional play for like majority of his life.
Oh, it's not like he was top 10 in Marvel Rivals solo queue only.
I thought it was so silly.
I honestly...
I was like, what the fuck?
Holy shit.
Anyway...
But yeah, this is like...
Yeah, where's my Wikipedia?
Where's my...
Everybody else has a Wikipedia but me.
I don't fucking understand.
This is proof that I should have a Wikipedia at that point.
Like, I honestly...
I should have a Wikipedia.
Also, another announcement.
If you guys didn't know...
I posted a link to it.
But...
My YouTube splashies are out now!
Wow!
So...
You can get a tomato me, alt girl me, or a croquis.
So all three of these splashies are out now.
And you can purchase them.
I pinned the link in the description.
I could like copy it again.
I have no use for a doki splash, but I definitely want to add a croquis or tomato one.
Please decide for me, chat.
Why not both mistakes?
If you haven't learned your lesson, you might as well get both splashies.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
I'm a variety VTuber in the pro category.
That's what I'm saying!
Even Calvin!
Calvin has hit like top 10.
He has hit rank 1 in multiple video games.
Which is understandable why he's in the pro category.
But like me in the pro category?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Which support organized two tournament winning Marble Rivals team again?
Back to fact, including sent members.
Sure for it, probably.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But yes, please check out the YouTube link.
Let me paste the link real quick.
Yes, check it out right now and support me and YouTube by getting your own official tomato, otoki, or croquis splash.
Right now!
It'll be up for 4 weeks.
Yes, buy my merch.
I love shilling.
It'll be only up for 4 weeks.
And then after 4 weeks, you'll never be able to purchase this again.
So, you should buy now.
Maybe the value will raise up.
You don't know that.
The value of these plushies can go up after that.
I don't know.
Or maybe go down.
That's what...
You gotta take your chances, guys.
Girls, thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm stuck in the elo held as plat.
Send help.
You know what's the easiest way to climb out of plat?
Play Rocket Raccoon.
You can have zero hands and still climb with Rocket Raccoon.
Eventually, you will be able to climb out of that elo.
I heard that a lot of people are now like...
That's not even ironic.
Unironically, if you really want to climb to GM+, just play Rocket Raccoon.
Because you'll eventually...
You just have to keep playing.
And you'll eventually get to that rank.
Because you gain more than you lose.
Skeleton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki helped me out of plat.
Now, I'm cool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There's so many inflated elo players right now in rank.
Because we didn't do a rank reset.
So, because we didn't do a rank...
Everyone's now complaining about how there's so many inflated players.
Because people can actually get to Celestial with a negative win rate.
And it's actually fucked up.
Medi, that's what I'm saying.
You're what?
No, I'm joking.
I'm...
I'm joking.
Anyway, anyway.
So, yeah, there's like...
Honestly, there's so many players that are like Celestial or Eternity.
That should not be in Celestial or Eternity.
GM, I think Grandmaster and Marble Rivals is like Diamond in Overwatch.
Honestly.
Or just Diamond.
It's just Diamond rank in general.
It's just way too easy to get to GM these days.
Okay,
look.
Guys, guys, look.
I...
I'm sorry.
I really have nothing to justify.
But last year, we did not have a lot of merch coming out last year.
Okay?
So, technically, you guys saved all your money from not buying my merch last year.
Because I had not a lot of merch coming out last year.
So, technically, this year is all just, you know, we are all building up to all...
Like, build up all the funds you saved from last year to buy this year's merch.
Right?
So...
So, technically, I'm catching up to all the lost merch from last year.
For this year.
But put on...
Well, you should have thought of that.
You should have thought of that sooner.
Guys.
What kind of...
A true Dragoon would have mortgaged...
No, don't mortgage.
I'm sorry.
I'm joking, guys.
Do not mortgage your home just to buy Doki Bird merch, guys.
I'm joking, everybody.
That is bad advice.
What I meant to say is that you should have gotten a loan from the...
I mean, no.
Sorry.
I'm also joking then.
That was also a joke.
What I meant to actually say is that...
Wait.
What I actually meant to say is that it's almost tax season.
And that means if you file your taxes properly, you're gonna get...
What do they call it?
Like the tax refunds and stuff?
Like the tax bonuses?
And so, if you file your taxes correctly, it means that you could use the refund you get from your taxes to buy more...
Tax returns!
Exactly!
So like, that's the whole...
That's why you have to make sure you do your taxes properly.
So by doing your taxes properly, you will get tax returns.
And by doing tax returns, you can spend that on more Doki merch.
Isn't that like...
Isn't that what it's supposed to be for?
Like...
Nice chat.
Tax returns is already busy filling the hole from...
Will I save the tax event?
What do you guys mean?
I pay...
I will pay my taxes.
Sorry.
Not yet.
I will pay my taxes.
Hold on.
Hi, Doki.
Here's my tax return.
Thank you for the super chat, Green Tea.
Thank you.
I make good choices, everyone.
Mercy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Claim my merch as a business expense on your taxes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If I talk about the things I buy, technically, it is a business expense.
Because me talking about the things I purchase is content.
And I'm making content out of it.
So technically, if I talk about every single purchase I make, they can technically be the business expenses.
So today, I ordered Uber Eats for...
Today, I felt like eating some Hong Kong cuisine.
So today, for my Uber Eats order, I ordered iced lemon tea.
And also,
I ordered pork with tomato sauce on it.
And it costed me around $20-$30 CAD.
Because I talked about it on stream.
And I made content out of it.
And you super chatted me because you were like, That's a great story, Doki.
Technically, it is a business expense.
If you think about it.
You need to take a photo.
Okay, I'll take a...
No, I can't.
I already threw it away.
I was gonna say, do I...
Am I willing to take a photo of my half-eating food and put it on my stream?
So I can write it off as a business expense?
I have the receipt, too.
I have the...
Very cool story.
Thank you, guys.
I really appreciate you guys enabling me to make very good decisions in my life.
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This girl, when she finally makes it back to Hong Kong.
So I had some xǔ lǒng bāo.
And that's totally a business expense magic.
I needed it for my Twitter post and content.
Exactly.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wolfhound, thank you for the super chat.
That's a great story, Dokia.
Good content.
Exactly.
If the auditors see this stream, they will know I wasn't lying about my Uber Eats order.
I technically...
If I eat my food while I'm streaming, is that a business expense?
What if I just start eating whenever I stream?
Every time...
Because I'm eating my food to make content.
I have to have food in my stomach to have enough energy to make content for my business.
Minimaxing taxes.
Everyone eats to work.
Yes, but that's not their job.
This is my job.
Okay, how about like...
What if...
If I do grocery shopping...
If I take pictures of all the groceries I buy...
And then I post it on social media...
And also show it on stream...
Is that a business expense?
Because I'm making content out of my groceries.
What if I just make up a story about the groceries I buy every time?
I'll be like, oh my god, you can't...
Oh my god, you can't...
You wouldn't believe it.
But today, while I was grocery shopping...
Anyway, here's a photo of my groceries.
Yes, I'm getting some...
How is that fried?
If there's a story that goes along with the groceries...
I don't...
You wouldn't believe...
It's not butter, guys.
If you take a picture of the food, it's like you're sponsored too.
How is... I don't understand.
How is it fried though?
I'm showing it on stream.
I'm making content out of it.
And you're reacting to my groceries.
How is that not...
How is that not a business expense?
I'm literally making money while I'm telling my story about grocery shopping.
That should be a business...
Every time I go do grocery shopping on the stream itself...
I do a review of the items.
And be like, okay, so I bought this today.
Do we have lawyers in here?
Doki's chat reacts to Doki's taxation.
At this point, just play Marvel Rivals.
Guys, guys, all I'm saying is that...
All I'm saying is that I make very good decisions in life.
LOL
Look, it's all about being an adult.
It's all about trial and error, okay?
I'm trying to trial and error life right now.
Trying to figure out what is considered a business expense and what isn't.
I don't know.
Like, there should be like...
There's no like, frequently asked questions for content creators when it comes to business expense.
Because technically, I can make anything into content.
Like...
Like, everything I buy can technically be content if I post about it on Twitter.
Or show it on stream if you think about it.
Because like, I am trying to...
I'm telling stories about it.
LOL She talks about tax fraud in the stream title of Make Good Choices.
J1, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, stop.
My CPA certificate is curling up in fear.
Gana, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, anyway.
Story time.
Not about like, tax fraud or anything.
But like, I just realized...
Okay, so...
Doki Amber Doge, dad, has had this like...
Has had this issue where he keeps like, kicking his blankets.
Okay, so I let dad sleep with me.
I let Doki Amber Doge sleep with me.
And so, we have two blankets.
And we have like, one is like, his favorite blanket.
But every time I like, leave to like...
I leave, you know, to my office to do work stuff.
And I come back, he like, kicks a blanket to the floor.
And then sleeps on the fucking floor.
Like a...
Like a fucking...
Like a caveman.
I don't understand.
I was like, why are you...
Are you homeless?
You're not homeless.
You have a fucking bed.
Why are you sleeping on the floor?
Like...
I work so hard, so you can live like this.
Why are you sleeping on the floor?
Like an animal.
He is a king in the palace.
Why...
I was like, why are you like this?
I make so much money, so you don't live like this.
What do you want to be like?
I was like, do you want to be poor?
What's wrong with you?
And he does that like every other day.
Like, I...
My mattress is an expensive mattress.
It's nice and soft.
And he would just kick the blanket.
And just...
Floor, good.
Say humble, my goat.
So like...
And then I would like come back.
And then I just see like...
I just see him like uncurled...
Like curled up underneath the blanket.
On the floor.
And I always have to like place the blanket back on the bed.
It's so annoying.
I just... I don't understand.
Bed hot.
It's not even cool.
It's carpeted.
The floor is...
It's not like it's an improvement.
The floor is carpeted and everything.
So it's not cooler.
It's...
And he's under the blanket.
He's under the blanket.
So he's making himself hot anyway.
He's...
Carpet.
Good.
It's not like he's like...
On top of the blanket.
He's like curled up.
Under the blanket too.
So it's not like it's cooler down there.
Yabby, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That is a hot conversation.
He likes a hard bed.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You wouldn't get it, Doki.
You're not like...
You're not one of the people.
But yeah, anyway.
That's basically...
It's a very short story time about Dad today.
Just cause like...
Also, I'm really proud of myself.
Because before the stream, I spent like...
I spent like two to three hours just cleaning my apartment.
And I actually vacuumed my...
I actually vacuumed my floors today.
When was the last time I vacuumed?
Don't worry about it.
But I did it.
Two hours is all...
Look.
Guys.
That was a long time of cleaning for me.
Okay?
Like, I'm not used to it.
Two hours was a lot.
Alright, guys?
It was...
It took a lot out of me.
So, anyway.
I also...
I vacuumed...
I also vacuumed the floors.
Not all the floors.
Obviously.
But just the places where I was like...
That's bad.
I was like...
I should really, really fix that.
And I actually booked a cleaning service on Sunday.
To actually clean my apartment.
Because it's not looking the greatest right now.
So like...
So now...
Look, I had two hours.
Do you really think I could get everything cleaned in two hours?
Guys!
It was either I not stream today...
Or...
Spend...
Half a day.
Not the whole day.
Like, I know my limits, guys.
I was like...
Is half a day too much?
Maybe not half a day.
That seems a lot too.
Anyway.
Half a day to clean my place.
Alright.
Anyway.
So...
You shouldn't have streamed.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for trying to fucking have a career.
You know how I need to pay the cleaners?
By streaming.
I'm at this fucking loop where...
To pay the cleaners...
I have to be able to stream...
So I can make enough money...
To pay for cleaners.
So I don't have time...
To clean my own home.
Because I'm trying to make money.
So because I don't have time...
To clean my own home...
I have to hire cleaners.
But then I need money.
So I have to stream.
And it's a never ending fucking cycle.
It's a...
Oh yeah.
And the cleaners are gonna be my business expense.
Cause I'm gonna make a story out of them.
So I can write them off as a tax return.
Capitalism.
Life is a prison.
Anyway.
That's just life.
CF.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are you live streaming the cleaners?
Does it count?
That's what I was...
Oh my god.
Do you think that's why XQC was streaming while cleaners were in his room?
So he could...
Because...
So he made the cleaners his content.
And because he made the cleaners his content...
He was able to write them off as a business expense.
Oh my god.
That is so smart.
I...
That is...
That is so fucking smart.
Oh my god.
He might be smarter than we all thought he was.
We cracked the code.
Okay.
What if...
But like what if...
I pretend to stream...
And I put in like...
I push...
Play a video...
Of like sound effects of people cleaning my room.
So I can pretend that that's them.
So it's not like doxworthy for me.
And then I can write it off as a business expense.
So it's like they're here.
Like...
Wait.
That's illegal.
Okay.
But like...
Wait.
Why would the CRA...
By the way, that's the IRS for Canada.
Why would the CRA even watch this stream?
Who's gonna rat me out?
Who's gonna...
I don't have...
Okay.
Who in chat actually works for the CRA?
The Canadian Revenue Agency.
Guys, I need to know.
Can anyone in my chat tell me if they work at the CRA?
Who said that?
Me?
Okay, goodbye, Yen.
I'm gonna...
Goodbye.
I can...
I can time...
It's okay.
The CRA cannot watch me anymore.
If they're banned from my chat...
Wait, I'm not Canadian.
I was...
I was kidding.
Look, alright.
Guys, it was that easy.
If I find out you work for the CRA, I'm gonna...
I'll make sure you...
I'll make sure you can't watch this anymore.
I don't think that's a good...
Real...
An undercover cop has to tell you if they're...
Exactly.
If I ask you, you have to tell me if you're a cop.
Okay, guys?
Yeah, he's not gonna be in the office any longer.
What the fuck is Justin gonna do to me?
Be careful about that, Doki.
Those cleaners will unionize at some point.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sounds like a good way to...
Okay, is there...
Are there any auditors in my chat as well?
Are there...
If I...
Wow!
For all you auditors that are watching...
Oh my god.
Do you guys ever...
Did you guys ever wanted free plushies of me?
Because clearly you're dragoons, right?
Oh my...
It would...
Oh...
If somehow...
A CRA employee...
Or auditor...
Slipped their address to my chat...
My business email...
And then in a couple of months...
They received...
Oh...
They received some free Doki merch...
Because of logistical error.
That...
Wow!
Now that...
No, no.
Logistical shipping error.
It's not...
I'm not bribing anyone.
It's just a mistake in the shipping.
Because...
I'm just covering my bases.
If somehow...
Some dragoons received free items...
Then like...
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
You guys must be so lucky...
For like logistical errors to come forth.
I'm sorry for that.
Sure, Doki.
Anyway...
Time to make some good choices today in life.
Anyway, let's play the game.
Speaking of good decisions that I make everyday...
Let's make some...
Let's make some good choices now.
I wonder if I...
Do I need to...
Okay, let me see.
Look sensitivity.
Alright.
I don't know how I found this game.
I don't know how...
Oh, what happened?
Oh yeah, for those who thought that I would be showing up to LM's birthday today...
I told him that I was only free at 2pm.
And then he like...
The thing that I was supposed to do got cancelled.
So like...
That's why I didn't show up.
So...
That's why I'm here now.
I was gonna do a 5pm stream regardless.
I said like...
I can only show up before 5.
So that's why...
That's why I didn't show up on LM's stream.
Anyway...
Anyway, it's time to make some good choices.
I don't know where I found this game.
There's no sound yet.
There's no sound, guys.
We're just on the main menu.
I had this in my Chrome tabs...
For the longest time.
And I don't know how I came forth to this game.
I just saved it.
It was like in my tabs.
And I was like...
Oh, I should play this game eventually.
And then today...
Like when I was making a schedule this week...
I was like...
Oh, I wanna do it really...
I wanna do it one-off.
And I was like...
You know what?
This is the time to finally play this game.
Make good choices.
And it's just all about making good decisions.
Why is the street light even capable of killing me?
So all I have to do...
Is get across that street...
To go home.
And it can't be that difficult.
I'm gonna get some water real quick.
Let me get some...
I'm so fucking...
Oh my god, I'm so fucking stupid.
Okay.
Not this game.
But...
I...
I made hot water...
Before this stream.
And I was like...
Okay, clearly the water...
Would be cold...
Like cooler by then.
And then I realized...
When I was boiling my hot water...
With my...
What is it called?
The boiling water thingy?
The...
What is it called?
What is the...
The thing called?
The boil what?
The kettle!
The kettle.
Sorry, I'm fucking stupid today.
I...
Left...
The cover...
Open...
So all the water...
Evaporated...
While it was boiling.
I...
The entire water evaporated.
I was like...
How?
I filled that up so much.
Like I filled it...
I actually filled it like...
All the way...
Like to like...
All the way up.
And the entire...
Oh my god.
I was so surprised.
It's gone.
It's all gone.
It's...
I accidentally made it.
I accidentally had a humidifier.
Fire
hazard.
Give me a sec.
Guys, it's okay.
Everything is okay.
Everything...
It's okay.
I...
Okay.
Everything is okay.
Okay, let's try this again.
Alright.
The vending machine knew.
It knew it was coming.
Okay.
So don't get near vending machines.
I'll just walk straight.
Alright.
The scooter's battery emitted sparks before detonating and you were caught in...
Oh shit.
Was that a scooter also made by Tesla?
Alright, that's five.
I just...
Won't...
That was not the same trap.
I...
The...
I walked on the gas leak.
Okay, I'll just go this way.
What's it gonna do?
The trash bag?
Improperly tightened bolts.
Let the AC slide free.
And it chose you as a target.
Is Doki Landlord onto you?
Wanna pre-flush you?
Thank you for the super chat.
Okay, I'll just go far left.
There you go.
What's it gonna do?
This car's gonna explode, right?
Okay.
Okay, so there's two Tesla cars here.
That's fine.
Now that I know...
That there's two Tesla cars.
I'll just go here.
So there was a gas leak on this road.
So, other...
Oh, okay, cool.
Okay.
What is this Tesla Avenue?
Shifting ground beneath the street light.
Did I just encounter an earthquake?
Where am I?
Where the fuck?
I just didn't get over there!
I didn't get across the street!
Okay.
There we go.
Okay, we found the pathing.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That truck...
That truck is a cyber truck right there.
I refuse to believe it's not.
There's gonna be a bomb from that door.
Wait, what?
What?
Am I gonna get seen?
Oh my...
Okay.
A corroded joint in the gas plate finally gave out just as you passed.
Triggering an explosion.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright.
I don't know...
I can't move him after he fucking gets his thing going.
Alright.
Just don't stand near that.
I'll stand in the middle.
It's the same thing?
What is the hitbox?
Love Final Destination the video game.
Phantom Knight.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, it's fine.
We figured out the pathing though.
It's here.
Okay, so what if I...
Go this way instead.
And then I go that way.
A hidden defect in the car's battery caused it to over...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the freedom.
I will never rat you out, my queen.
I just woke up and I just hopped on the stream and the first thing I hear is...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How many fucking Teslas are around me?
Wait, there's a trash can here now.
Wait, they block...
What the fuck?
They can just do that?
Oh, wait.
The scooter's gone.
That is so fucked up.
Are you fucking...
They changed the map?
How do I remember this?
No, I can't believe it.
No, they put the scooter...
Oh, wait.
The air conditioner's gone.
The AC's gone.
Okay.
Where do I go?
Wait, was this...
Was this the thing that fell on me?
I don't remember.
Wait, what if I go here?
No.
No!
A chain reaction.
Falling debris.
Loosen.
What the fuck was that?
Okay.
That's fine.
This cone is gone, so that means I can go this way now.
Oh my god, I don't remember.
The car's gone, so there's no Teslas here.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god.
Wait, the car's gone, so I can go here this way.
I don't remember.
Wait, is this a Tesla?
Is this a Tesla?
Doki Life Simulator.
All the bad luck happens to you.
Yeah, I mean, thank you for the super chat thing.
Is this a Tesla?
I don't remember.
Wait, that's...
That's the dish that killed me.
No, but if I go this way, this will kill me.
Okay.
Just don't die.
Oh my god, just don't die, Doki.
What's the worst that could happen?
Just don't fucking die.
How do I get across?
I just...
Oh my god, why can't I just call an Uber?
Where are my Ubers?
Just like this.
Oh my god, I can't remember all the traps.
I can't.
I tried...
The Uber would explode.
Have you tried making good decisions?
Wait, was it here?
Okay.
This car explodes.
But I go this way.
I...
How?
Oh my god, okay.
Okay, the car is...
Okay, this way.
I...
It's too many.
Okay, this way again.
Surely it won't happen.
It's like, oh, it won't happen a second time.
I knew it.
Okay, the car is gone.
The...
Oh my god.
Cone is the worst.
Okay.
The cone means it'll fall on me.
Okay, I get it.
I get it now.
If there's a cone, that means it'll fall on me.
So as long as I don't stand near the cone, we'll be fine.
Okay.
There's nothing...
That looks very safe though.
That...
That looks incredibly safe.
Oh, there's a bike ahead, so I shouldn't get near it.
Alright.
What if I just keep going...
Oh no, that AC is definitely gonna hit me.
I have a feeling.
Okay, no AC here.
And there's no cars too.
This buil...
I was gonna say, no way this building is gonna crash on me.
No way.
There's...
There's sounds like, oh man, we'll be fine.
It's not like this building is gonna crash on me or anything.
Oh, that's...
That would be so ridiculous.
There's no fucking way that's gonna happen.
Okay, there's no cone here, so this place is safe.
That would be so silly.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, this...
Oh my god, this trash can does not...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh my god, okay, that...
That doesn't look like...
Oh my god, that looks like a trash can with a fucking Tesla in it.
I fucking...
Ow!
If I get near the trash can, it'll just explode.
Okay.
There's no car...
There's no bike this time.
So I should be fine.
And then there's no cone here, so I should be fine here too.
And then...
Okay, we go this way.
There's nothing above me.
So I should be fine too.
And then we just keep going this way because...
Oh, that...
What?
Run!
No!
Where are the people?
Where did everybody go?
How would I know?
Okay, we go this way.
I'm so far!
I'm so far away!
Why can I not just walk to the left?
I don't understand.
Just walk two footsteps up right.
Oh no.
The aircon is gone.
Does this mean it explodes?
A cigarette carelessly tossed into the garbage and I wasn't there.
Guys...
Look, I'm all about like the scientific theory, okay guys?
How the fuck would I know?
I don't know.
I thought it could be a smoking kills.
Guys, this is why you shouldn't smoke, guys.
Okay.
Alright.
We can go this way.
Okay.
We go this way and then we go this way.
As long as we're not near that car, it should be fine.
I...
Oh my God!
God, I'm so fucking pissed.
I just need to cross the street.
I need to get to the other side of the street.
Is that too much to ask for?
Does it sound like they're still there?
I don't think so.
I think it's gone.
Yeah, it's gone.
It's gone, guys.
Okay.
And then obviously, that trash can should explode.
Fudge top, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Skill issue.
Okay.
Unlucky, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Lay in bed and turn two degrees to the right.
Bedsheet explodes.
Okay.
Okay, so that trash can obviously explodes.
And then...
And then the traffic cones means that the light pole...
This pole will fucking kill me.
So what if I just go this way?
And the car may or may not explode.
But that's the risk I'm gonna take.
Oh my god, I'm okay.
Alright.
Now, we go straight.
Okay, but I could go...
Okay.
Okay, well now we know white buckets are dangerous, guys.
Do not go near white buckets.
Alright, now that we figured that out, I could go straight here.
Because there's no pole here right now.
So that means I can just go straight.
And then after that, I go this way.
Because that roof is gonna fall on me.
And then I just go straight.
And this will fall on me too.
And there's an exploding Tesla bike right here.
So I go this way.
And then there's no way that would get me.
Because I'm so far away.
And then...
What do I do?
What do I do after this?
I've never made...
Oh, look up.
Look up what?
Where do I...
Where do I go?
Look both ways.
Okay.
Alright.
This seems...
Where would this traffic cone be for?
Oh, I have to wait.
Okay.
What do you mean?
I even waited.
I waited for it to turn green.
Okay.
Okay, we'll just go this way.
Okay, I forgot about the traffic cone.
This is everything my parents said would happen to me.
If I try to walk to my friend's house by myself.
Okay.
We go this way.
There's no cars.
Alright.
And then...
Anything above me?
No?
Okay.
And then we cross the street.
Kyle, thank you for the magenta soup.
I...
I don't understand.
Okay.
Is this a simulation built by Elon Musk?
Like, where am I?
Is this why this whole area is empty?
Am I in a fucking simulation right now?
Am I?
But where am I?
Oh my god, there's a satellite dish above me.
But then there's this.
There's gonna be a fucking gas leak.
I'm just trapped.
There's nothing I can do.
There's nothing...
There's nothing I can do!
There's even a bomb next to me!
What does the gas leak pipe look like?
I don't remember.
What does...
Is that the gas leak pipe?
Wait, is this what the gas...
Is it...
Oh, it's cause it's rusted, right?
If it's rusted, it's the gas leak pipe?
Oh my god, you guys are so smart.
You guys are so much more...
I fucking...
I hate life.
I...
Okay, if there's rust on it, it's the gas leak pipe.
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out, guys.
If there's rust on it, it's the gas leak pipe.
Okay, that...
Eh.
Okay.
Fuck, okay.
We go this way because...
This cone is where the...
I...
There's an AC!
There's an... I never look up!
Every day!
I don't look up!
Kyle, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you for the super chat!
I just don't look up!
Why don't I ever look up?
I don't understand!
Okay.
A sand in the middle.
There's no gas leaks over there.
So I'll go this way.
There's the vending machine.
We don't touch the vending machine, guys.
There's the exploding scooter.
So I'll just go this way.
Okay.
What do you mean no traces of explosion?
I'm literally living through it!
What do you mean?
What?
There's lore?
Am I dead?
Is this my fucking personal hell?
Is this my personal hell?
No.
Okay.
Alright.
Wait for the green.
We wait for the green.
There we go.
We made it.
Oh my god.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you.
Grundy, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
I'm across the street.
I don't even know where the...
I forgot where the end goal was.
Oh my god, we're across the street.
Where the fuck do I go?
I've never been this far before.
He's just waiting there.
That car was just waiting for me.
Surely this humble bike won't fucking...
Guys, it wasn't the bike, guys.
Wow!
It wasn't the bike, who would've thought?
It wasn't the fucking bike, guys.
Okay.
This car is gonna explode, I can feel it.
I can feel the explosion right there.
Okay.
Right.
That bucket would explode, I know it.
Okay.
We cross here.
And that scooter is gonna explode on me.
Okay.
Alright.
We figured out street one, guys.
We figured out street one.
This is why you don't go outside, chat.
The outside is so fucking dangerous.
NotSoDeadpool, thank you for the super chat.
I'm fucking out!
But there was no one in the car!
He waited!
He waited just for me!
That's so fucked up!
That car waited!
He could've drove at any moment, but he waited for me.
That is so fucked up!
It was planned!
It was all planned!
They're all out to get me, guys!
I knew it!
I fucked...
I knew you guys called me crazy, but I knew they were all out to get me.
No!
Wait!
Wait, I...
I lived!
I got an achievement!
Oh, my God!
There is a God!
I'm alive!
Oh, my God!
I defiled death!
Wait, there was a person up there?
Wait, what?
I didn't see him!
I knew it!
I knew they were out to get me!
I fucking knew it!
Oh, my God!
I defied death!
Okay, that would kill me.
Oh, my God, I don't know what the pattern is for this.
I...
That scooter would explode.
I can feel it.
I can feel the explosion on that scooter.
Oh, my God, where do I go?
There's an AC unit here.
Oh, my God, I'm so nervous!
I'm so nervous.
Where do I go?
What does the sign mean?
Guys, it does not look safe, guys.
It absolutely does not look safe.
Oh, my God, I don't know.
Maybe...
Okay.
Okay, these bikes...
Wait, what?
There he is?
Where's the guy?
You see someone?
Where?
Oh!
Oh, my God, there he is!
Oh, he's looking...
Oh, my...
He's gone.
Oh, that actually gave me goosebumps.
That actually gave me goosebumps right there.
Oh, my God.
Is that him?
Is that Elon Musk?
I'm testing out his test notes right now.
Oh, my God, is that him?
Actual Elon Musk.
Oh, my God.
The man works for the CIA.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Burrito.
Okay.
Guys, do you think those bikes are safe?
Because I can't tell.
I can't walk here because there's a fucking telephone pole in front of me.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, there's a trash can, guys.
Guys!
There's a trash can!
There's a bucket!
What do I do?
Do I just die?
It's just a bucket.
Okay.
Who said that?
Who the fuck...
Who said it was...
It's a...
It's a bucket.
What the fuck?
What the fuck I said?
It's a bucket.
It's just a bucket.
SpookyMcPot.
This guy...
Told me...
It's a bucket.
It's just a bucket.
Yeah, it's a bucket.
So no one got it.
Well, it was a bucket.
Where's the lie?
Oh, you're right, guys.
It was a bucket, guys.
It was...
It was, in fact, a...
He just forgot to put the word...
Exploding bucket.
He's just...
They're not wrong.
You're right, guys.
Just forgot an important word.
He just forgot to put exploding in there.
Oh, you're so right, guys.
You're so right.
Silly me.
Oh, I'm so silly.
Oh, silly, silly me.
How could I have not known it was exploding bucket?
I...
Oh my god.
I didn't see the fucking pipe leak.
This is the worst version of Groundhog Day to be stuck in.
I swear.
Jack, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, so silly.
So very silly.
Okay, there's a satellite dish.
Okay.
There's the...
There's the fucking exploding bucket.
Okay.
I'll go to this side.
There's no gas leak over there this time.
And I'll go to this side to avoid the scooter.
Okay, I wait.
I'm patient.
Oh my god, I'm so patient.
Okay.
And then, there's the thing that...
The satellite thing that would fucking crash me.
And we go this way.
Okay.
Wait, there's no...
No, there's the bucket.
I see the bucket.
I see the bucket, guys.
I see it.
It's right there.
Oh my god.
There's no gas leak here, so...
Should be fine.
There's nothing above me.
Okay.
There's the exploding trash can.
Is there anything above me?
Wait, is that the gas leak pipe?
That's not, right?
That's not...
Yeah, but as long as I'm not near the vending machine, it should be fine.
Okay.
I'm not near it.
The worst that could happen.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
That's good.
We're making good progress.
There's nothing above me here either.
Anything above me?
No?
Okay.
We're almost there.
I can see it.
I can see the end of...
I'm making good decisions, guys.
I'm making really good decisions right now.
If I go forward...
That's not the gas leak pipe.
Expert, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's...
Oh my god.
I can't go through because there's that.
And that's the fucking exploding trash can.
I know you explode.
Okay.
That bucket explodes.
So...
If I just go straight...
Yeah?
Okay.
And then...
Go straight forward.
It's a bucket.
Yes, it is.
Just a bucket, guys, right?
Just a bucket.
Nothing is gonna fucking kill me.
And then...
I go straight forward.
Oh, I can't go straight forward because...
There's this.
That will fall.
But there's a bucket.
But where do I go?
I know that explodes.
I know that fucking...
That explodes too.
Oh no, where do I go?
There's two buckets.
Look at this.
Look at the pothole.
What is it called?
The sewer thingies.
I don't believe.
I don't believe that's safe.
That cannot be safe.
There's no way.
There's a traffic cone.
That's a landmine.
That might as well fucking explode and then the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles come out.
I don't fucking know.
That manhole, I can tell it.
It's like a little...
It's like a fucking...
It's like step on me.
I'm a goddamn man.
I'm a goddamn...
I have a goddamn mind.
Like, it's literally just screaming at me that it's a mine.
Yeah.
Thank God.
Trust no one.
Okay, I got an idea.
Oh no, that fucking falls.
Never mind.
That AC.
There's no way that AC doesn't fall.
There's no way.
Oh no, I'm trapped.
I'm fucking trapped.
Give it a chance.
Okay.
Oh my God, it's safe.
What the fuck?
Who's in there?
Who the fuck is there?
I don't feel safe at all.
Music of death.
It's like the music that plays in Final Destination before you fucking die.
Oh my God, it's the Grim Reaper.
Okay.
Just gotta get across.
Okay, that falls.
That satellite dish falls so we can't be near it.
But we can't be near it.
Where can we go?
Okay, we gotta go across.
From here?
We gotta go across from there.
Oh, the music stopped.
I don't know if I like the music being... stopping.
Okay.
There's nothing.
Look both sides of the road, chat.
Look both sides.
Ah, yes, my Oshi.
Paranoid bird.
They're all out to get me.
You don't understand.
Okay.
No, but if I go this way, the fucking TV satellite dish is gonna kill me.
Thank you for the very first super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my God.
Please.
Okay.
Oh no, not the scooter.
Not the fucking scooter.
Not the...
Where do I go?
No!
Okay, we go from inside.
There's no way this building collapses on me.
There's no fucking way.
Oh my God, gravity physics has not hurt me yet.
Oh.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, physics.
Oh my God, I beat physics!
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, I won against physics, guys.
Oh my God, there's a car.
There's a fucking car.
There's a car.
Okay.
We got this.
Alright.
We crossed the road.
And then we crossed the road again.
Okay.
Okay, we gotta make sure that we don't die from that car.
Okay, it's right there.
It's right there.
He's waiting for me.
No!
Who built the room?
Who built this room?
Oh my God.
Who's the contractor?
Who was he?
Oh my God.
Who fucking hired this contractor?
You know Elon built it.
Oh.
Is that...
I can't...
Oh no, that's the gas leak pipe.
Okay.
Brick?
Well...
If it's brick...
If it's brick, that means it kills.
Pan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I just watched the MySummerCarVlog.
Where Doki faced the last report map for 2 hours and 30 minutes.
And now this.
Good luck.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, this is safe.
Okay.
I...
I forgot to go around it.
It's been so long.
I forgot all about it.
It's been too long.
I've been trapped in fucking purgatory.
Okay.
I've been trapped in this hellhole.
Only I can run.
Guys, I don't...
Guys, I know I can run.
But when I start running, I start forgetting.
You have to know.
When I start running, I start forgetting.
So it's easier if I don't run.
It's...
Yoshi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Kaboom, baby.
Johnny and Deadpool, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Osni, thank you for the super chat.
I don't usually do this, but I sent a super chat earlier.
And I think it could help both of us.
Thank you for the super chat, Osni.
Thank you, thank you.
Osni, thank you for the super chat.
Speaking of good decisions, I'm really fed up with my current job.
I need to find a new one.
Can I hear your most serious...
Can you lock the fuck in?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, I swear to God.
I'm locking in.
Guys, everything kills me.
What do you want from me?
There's a fucking bucket.
Okay, this falls.
This falls.
Okay.
Wait, where do I go?
Are you se...
There's a... God damn it!
What the fuck?
I can't get out of the first street.
Okay.
There's no AC anymore.
I want you to be in a good news.
You haven't filmed me yet.
Thank you for the super chat.
I can't...
Why did the city go through so many budget cuts?
Who made this city?
This AC will kill me.
There's the gas leak pipe.
Okay.
We built this city.
Walk on the green light.
Doki.
Alright.
Okay.
What do I do now?
Okay, there's a trash can.
Okay.
There's...
I don't trust those red bins.
Those red bins... It's just sitting there.
It's just sitting there.
There's no way it doesn't explode.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But like...
Okay, I could walk around that, right?
There's no way.
There's no way that doesn't...
It's just sitting there.
Menacingly.
Like, it's just sitting there.
I don't know if I should risk it.
Okay.
What if I just go this way?
I go around.
Oh, there's an AC.
Oh, there's that fucking AC.
Not all ACs will kill me, right?
There's your ass.
How was I supposed to know?
I just... I don't know.
I thought there'd be safe ACs.
Okay, we go this way.
I thought some air cons would be safe.
Okay.
That's a gas leak, pilot.
Just go this way.
And then...
Now go this way.
Oh, that was the safest.
The city ghost gets five big booms!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Boom, boom, boom!
Okay.
I figured it out.
I figured it out, guys.
There's no way that thing could hurt me.
My god, I'm right.
Oh my god, I'm right.
What else could I be right for?
My god.
I'm actually right.
Oh, but there's...
Oh, is there a bucket?
There's no bucket, guys.
Guys, there's no bucket.
Guys.
Guys, the bucket's gone.
Okay.
Okay, there's no bucket.
Bucket's gone.
There's still hope in this world.
There's another bucket here.
Okay.
We go this way.
I'm so fucking scared.
Does this fall?
I can't tell.
I can't tell if it falls.
Oh my god.
I...
It's fucking sad.
Okay, I figured it out, guys.
Okay, the first street is easy.
The first... I figured... It's the first street.
I... I...
Okay.
I figured it out, guys.
The first street, I know how this goes.
I know how the first street goes, guys.
I played these games before.
I figured it out.
I fucking figured it out, guys.
I swear to god.
Please don't understand.
I don't understand.
Where do I go?
I don't remember how to play this game.
It's been so long.
Oh my god.
Okay.
The satellite dish is right there.
I can go straight now.
I should really go straight.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm fine.
I'm perfectly fine.
Everybody.
Don't worry.
I'm...
That falls.
Oh god.
It's a bucket.
I can't get anything done now.
JR, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sam, thank you for the super chat.
Welcome to Latin America, Turkey.
Believe me.
I know what I'm talking about.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, we figured it out.
Go, go, go, go.
Okay.
Sign kills.
Sign kills, Doki.
Okay.
That's safe.
That's not the scary bucket.
There's an AC somewhere.
I know you're around here.
Not the scooter.
Okay.
Hug the wall.
The scooter can't kill you if you hug the wall.
Doki, please.
Please, I'm going through some things right now.
Please, I'm going through a lot right now.
That kills.
That's a sign.
Oh no.
Okay.
There's a bucket.
Okay, we go this way.
The manhole.
No!
Why would they do this to me?
Why would they?
Why would they stop sparking?
It was warning me.
It was warning.
He's like, look up.
Look up, Doki.
Look up.
I didn't listen to him.
Why did I listen to him?
He warned you.
He was trying to warn you, Doki, but you didn't listen.
I didn't know.
I'm sorry.
Now he's angry.
He's like, how could you not know?
The signs were all there.
Okay.
Okay, we got through the first street.
The AC is gone.
I should be able to cross this way.
It's gone.
Okay.
There's no bucket.
Guys, there's no bucket.
Bucket's not there.
There's no satellite dish.
I got a little paranoid.
I had to look up just in case.
I got a little freaked out.
I had to be sure.
Can I...
Can I walk past the trash can?
Is that possible?
Can I...
Will it let me?
Will it let me walk past you?
Oh my god, it let me.
No!
I was so happy.
I was like, oh my god, I did it.
I made it past the trash can.
But it was him.
The gas leak pipe.
It was an ambush.
The trash can was bait all along.
It was just bait.
I'm so fucked up.
It was just a bait.
It knew.
It fucking knew.
I hate it when that happens.
No!
I forgot what that car...
It's been so long since a car exploded.
I forgot what that was like.
Oh my god, please.
No, not the gas leak pipe.
I forgot.
It's been so long since I got exploded by a car.
It's been so long.
Oh my god, I'm so paranoid.
I'm like, what is around me right now?
There's a gas leak pipe right here too.
There's a fucking AC.
Okay.
Cross the road.
I'm so tired.
I fucking... I'm dying everyday.
Okay.
Okay, I should be able to just walk straight.
Technically.
Technically, nothing should kill me if I walk straight.
Is there a bucket?
There's no bucket.
Guys, there's no bucket.
There's no bucket over there.
Oh, there's no gas leaks.
There's a gas leak over there.
But there's no gas leak over here.
There's a side like this, but that's fine.
As long as I go like that, we're okay.
Where do I go now?
There's a bucket.
There's a side like this.
What do I do?
What do I...
Can I cross?
Can I just cross the road?
Just like that?
My...
Okay.
I don't know what to do now.
I don't...
There's a side.
Okay.
And if I go straight...
Straight and then past this...
Things will be...
Alright.
Okay.
And then I go straight.
Alright.
Okay.
I'm a broken man.
I can't trust nobody.
I...
I don't know.
I don't...
This is a gas leak pipe.
I don't know.
I...
No!
It's the pipe!
It is!
It is the pipe!
It's the gas leak pipe!
Of fucking course it is!
What else could it be?!
What fucking else could this fucking be?!
Oh my god.
Please.
You built this!
Who built this place?!
Where's the inspector?!
Why is nothing being inspected?!
The revenge of the gas.
Please.
I just...
Please, just let me go.
Free me.
Okay, there's nothing here.
We can walk past.
Is there a bucket?
There's a bucket.
They have a bucket.
Sir, they have a bucket.
I just need to hug this.
Hug this and then go here.
So I don't get killed by the side.
And then after that...
Okay.
We go this way.
And then we hug this wall.
Milad, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Coming into this without context is pretty hilarious.
Listen to your paranoia.
You can't trust nobody here in the city.
Anything can be a fucking bomb!
Nothing is real!
Milad, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Love is in the air.
Wrongcastle.
Thank you for your favorite super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The buckets.
They're out to get me.
I didn't even see anything!
What the fuck?
The sun was in my eye!
That's not fair!
It was the sun!
Who the fuck let...
This is why global warming should exist.
Oh wait, no.
Global warming.
This is why we gotta make sure we fix the world.
Look what happened!
We have global warming!
And look what happened to us!
It blocked my vision!
We gotta fix the planet!
Or cause more pollution!
One or the other can solve the issues I have!
I'm gonna just start polluting more!
Just start polluting more!
Or fix global warming, I don't care!
I don't care anymore!
Bandit.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And they wonder why I don't go outside and touch grass.
Damn, don't keep pickling.
Whatever fucking kills the sun first, I don't care.
Okay.
Alright.
Go this way, there's no AC here.
Okay, everything should be fine here.
Alright.
We gotta wait, we gotta wait.
Where is Captain Planet when I need him the most?
Where is he?
Okay.
We can go straight.
And then, there's a bucket.
So because there's a bucket, I can go this way.
Is there any signs?
Anything?
No?
Okay.
Any signs?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Oh, this feels way too safe.
Oh!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Air conditioner be upon you.
Is there any air conditioning there?
Anywhere?
Can I just go straight?
This feels way too safe.
Oh.
Oh, I felt way too safe.
Wait.
Why is there nothing here?
I don't like that.
There's not even...
Why is there nothing?
Why?
Don't like it.
It's a trick.
They're trying to make me have a false sense of security.
There's no way.
There's no sign here too.
What the fuck is wrong with this?
Who built this simulation?
There's no sign.
I don't understand.
It's like they want me to just go forward.
Oh, but I know what your plans are.
I know what it is.
There's the pipe.
I know I see you.
I see you.
You think I forgot about you.
You put me in a false sense of security.
But I remember.
I remember you.
I know what you are.
Here.
No!
I don't put...
I don't put that there.
Oh my god.
Oh my...
The AC and pipe were about to get me.
They teamed up together.
Get pranked, bro.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All of this just so you can go to the doctor and learn about your impending doom from cancer.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're all out to get me.
It's all there.
Fuck y'all.
Every single one of them.
I have to go this way.
Oh my god, there's the bucket.
There it is.
Okay.
There's the AC.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm not rushing through that road.
I'm not rushing through it.
It's okay.
We can do this.
Okay.
We made it.
Just go forward.
Should be okay.
God, I can't see the fucking sun.
The fucking sun.
The fucking sun is covering everything up.
Is there a bucket?
Okay, wait.
No bucket.
Free roam.
Okay.
Alright.
Sign there.
And there's a bucket there.
There's an air conditioner there.
There's a pipe.
There's a sign.
Where the fuck do I go?
What?
There's a sign here.
There's a fucking pipe here and a trash can.
There's a cone here.
I can't.
Do you not see the pipe?
Between the pipe and the pipe.
Where do I go?
The trash can.
It's gonna explode.
Just send it.
Just...
Just try.
They blocked the entire path.
How the fuck was...
They blocked everything.
That was so fucked up.
There was no winning.
There was actual no winning.
They blocked the entire path.
It was rigged.
I was not born to succeed there.
The rich only gets richer.
Everything was set up against me from birth.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go again.
There's a bike.
The pole will explode.
There's an AC.
Okay, there's a bucket.
Go this way.
Sign is here.
Okay.
I gotta make sure I don't go to the side.
Oh my god, there's the bucket.
What do I do?
Wait.
There's no way that AC can follow me.
I'm on the right side of the road.
Okay.
Okay, this...
This fucked up area.
This area is so fucked up.
This is like one of the most fucked up areas.
Like, I don't know what to do.
This entire block is out to fucking kill me.
There's a sign there, so I can't go through.
Okay.
I have an idea.
My... and then I don't know.
And then I don't know.
That's where my idea stops, guys.
That's where it ends.
That's where my idea ends, guys.
But what if this explodes?
Okay, we'll wait.
We'll wait before we cross.
Okay.
Okay, we're here now.
It's right there.
I see it.
It's all the way right there.
Does this fall?
I can't tell.
I can't tell anymore.
Does that fall?
I don't know.
Everything out is trying to kill me.
There's an AC?
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Oh.
God, and the moment you get to the end, the sounds on your back are insane.
Where was the AC again?
I don't remember.
I don't remember where the AC was.
This car explodes.
There's no way.
There's the AC.
There's no way this is free.
I don't believe it.
I don't think anything in life is free anymore.
I don't...
Oh, my God.
None of...
Why are there so many TV satellite dishes?
Who lives here?
It's one, two, three points.
Oh, my God.
I don't...
Where am I?
Make good choices?
It's more like make paranoia field choices.
And a goofy ass simulator that runs on Murphy's Law and steroids.
Here, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Where's the code?
There's the fucking code.
There it is.
But where do I go?
This...
There's a satellite dish and this bike explodes.
There's a sign.
And then there's another satellite dish.
No, is that a good fucking code or a bad code?
I can't tell.
It's not on the road.
Oh, my God.
Is that a bad balcony?
Oh, God.
Bad code.
How would you know?
Where do I go?
There's a satellite dish right there.
That's gonna fall on my fucking head if I go this way.
I don't know anymore.
I don't know.
It's all...
No, there's a bad balcony.
There's bad balconies.
I found out there's bad balconies.
Do I trust the code?
I could go this way and go that way.
But if I go this way and that way...
Would I be safe if I do that?
Is this a bad balcony?
I can't tell.
I can't tell if this is a bad balcony or a good balcony.
I don't know.
I don't...
Imagine if a dev only bootstrapped the first two thirds of the game just to drive the people who play insane at parent...
I don't know the dev, but anyway, just something I would do.
Wings, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
No!
It was a bad code.
Guys, it was...
Guys, it was a bad code.
It was...
It was a bad code, everyone.
It was a very bad code.
It was a bad code.
Guys.
It was not a good code.
All codes are bad.
Every code is bad.
Every code...
ECI...
ECIB...
E...
Why?
So close.
Don't trust codes.
TD...
DTC...
Don't trust codes.
No code was born right.
No code was born good, guys.
Every code is bad.
Oh my god.
I'm so sad.
I was so close.
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
I can just walk straight.
I can...
Why did they just let me do that?
I don't understand.
I don't...
I can just walk straight.
I don't understand.
What's in it for them?
What's...
Why are they treating me like this?
I don't understand.
Why...
I don't...
I don't understand.
Why can I just do that?
I...
I don't understand.
Why...
Why is it safe?
What do they have planned for me?
It must be a trap.
It has to be a trap.
There's no way.
See, I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
Oh, I knew it.
It's too good to be true.
Let's go straight.
Okay.
Don't go through yet.
Is there...
Is there anything over there?
Okay.
Is there any ACs?
Anything?
What?
It's self-moving?
I knew it!
I knew this was a town built by Elon Musk!
I fucking knew it!
And myself got a sick experiment for him!
I knew it!
This is what's gonna happen, guys.
This is what's gonna happen to us.
To all of us!
I can feel it!
Okay, we just go straight.
It's a lie.
This is what's gonna happen.
This is his big plan!
This is what the Doge...
Whatever the Doge fucking government bodies for.
It's all connecting!
Oh my god, he's after me.
He's after all of you.
He's after all of us.
It's the lizard people.
Can I just walk straight?
Is that possible?
Am I allowed to?
No.
There's the cone.
There it is.
I fucking see you.
I see you.
I know you're there.
You think...
Oh, and then there's the satellite dish.
Oh!
What do I do?
Do I need air cons?
I just...
go straight?
Am I allowed to?
Do I have permission?
Do I...
Do I just...
Is this a bad balcony?
I can't tell.
I can't...
They're all so bad.
This is what happened to the chimpanzee with neural link.
Thank you for the super chat.
Are you...
Are you bad?
Are you good or a bad balcony?
I can't tell.
Oh, there's a satellite dish.
There's a satellite dish.
It's gonna follow me.
I'm gonna fucking die.
It's gonna follow me right here.
Right now.
Where do I go?
It's right there.
Can I do it?
Hello?
Where do I go?
There's so many dangerous things.
Which door?
Which one?
There's a left door.
There's a right door with two buckets.
There's two buckets.
I don't know.
Which is my house?
This one?
I made 53 bad choices.
I fucking did it.
Oh my god.
I can't.
I don't wanna go outside.
Don't worry.
Guys, I don't wanna go outside.
The outside is scary.
Oh my god.
See you guys.
I told you I can make good choices, guys.
I told you.
Everything's coming to get me.
I don't know what's good anymore and what's bad.
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Imagine you're watching the stream in a public spot and accidentally disconnected the Bluetooth.
People will think you lost your marbles.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There's no such thing as good cones.
Every cone is evil.
There's no such thing.
There you go.
Every cone is evil.
Wait, no.
Every cone is bad.
There we go.
All cone.
Every cone is bad.
Oh my god.
That was so fucking hard.
I was so paranoid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let's go.
Blasty, thank you for the very first super chat.
Thank you.
And then a meteor hits.
Try again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It felt really satisfying playing a game that lets you destroy buildings after this.
Wings, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
I'm tired.
That actually took so much out of me, chat.
That...
What about ice cream, Doki?
What about ice cream?
That's why I only use cup.
Guys, I actually don't like ice cream in a cone.
See, this actually backs up what I say.
Every cone is bad.
This backs it up.
I'm a cup type of gal.
I always use cup for ice cream.
Oh my god.
I have like mental exhaustion after that.
That...
It's like...
I'm just like...
Everything I touch explodes.
Everything...
What can I touch that doesn't explode?
What is it?
I was trapped in there to live through my personal hell.
I went through it.
Even when I thought for one time...
One time in my life, I was like...
Maybe this will be a good cone.
You know?
It's placed next to the pole.
That's different.
But no, every cone is bad.
Every...
They have no redeeming qualities.
They were born bad at birth.
There was nothing to save them.
There's no reform.
You cannot reform a cone.
They were all meant to be bad.
Magical.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
That was a good game though.
I'm gonna call it here everybody.
Don't keep...
Can't say that.
Is this the new merch?
What if I make a...
What if I just sell a black t-shirt?
And then my...
The only thing that's on the front is just...
Every cone is bad.
E-cib.
No.
The front will just be E-C-I-B.
And then the back will be like...
Every cone is bad.
And then like the front will have like...
Will just have like a...
You know?
Like a cone.
A picture of a cone.
And then an X sign on it.
And then...
New merch idea.
Zero...
Like zero context.
That's the one.
We're starting a movement.
Fuck cones.
Okay.
Then uninstall VLC.
Here, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is gonna be my new...
Guys, this is my new design idea.
Okay, guys.
For those who can't...
Who can't visual...
Need visualization for designs.
Okay, don't worry.
Alright, I'm drawing it out right now.
E...
C...
I...
B...
And then there's the cone.
And then...
And then the front...
Is...
Every...
Cone...
Is...
Bad.
This is my million dollar shirt idea.
Right there.
This is my...
This is my million dollar shirt idea.
I think I can...
I think I can see this in Walmart.
I can definitely see this in Walmart right now.
So that's the front design.
And that's the back...
The back design.
You can get it at your local Walmart.
It would be...
There we go.
That's the cone right there.
I'm sorry.
I did this in pain, guys.
I literally did...
You guys counted how long it took me to draw this.
It literally took me like 30 seconds to draw this.
The cone PTSD.
There you go.
That's my million dollar shirt idea.
My new merch drop, guys.
What do you have against Doritos?
I don't know.
Maybe they should have made it cone shaped.
I love that it's not even a cone.
What do you mean?
It looks like...
It's triangle.
How do I make it less...
How do I make it more of a cone?
It's shaped like a fucking triangle.
What the fuck do you mean?
Anyway, guys.
Before we end it here...
Before we end it here, buy my merch.
Before I go.
Before I go, guys.
Buy my merch, guys.
I am selling my new plushie.
It's live right now.
Buy my merch.
So you too...
So you don't have to go outside ever again and encounter a cone.
Where's the cone merch?
Soon, soon, guys.
Anyway, I'm gonna call it here.
Everybody.
As always, everyone.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and...
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
Get up and move around.
Sorry, like...
I'm sorry.
My paranoia is fucking me up right now.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
And if you sit after me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.